Oh
toi
[Musique]
depuis 1970 car le domaine de la villa est
devenu un lieu patrimonial un musée
qui présente l'histoire de ceux qui ont
construit ses salles une riche famille créole de
planteurs l'éventail sur le bouton puis
les vagues le lieu d'une
organisation sociale impactée  par une servitude
nommée par esclavage et jauges et
colonie partielle être sur l'eau et de ce qui
est donné à voir c'est un espace entre
parenthèses et temps dans lequel
cohabitent imagination et réalité Madame de Botton
décédée le 4 février 1846 veille
toujours  le
musée historique de la villa comme sa propre identité
et le film plus loin, le musée entre parenthèses en
propose une interprétation politique
[Musique]